the dark lord shall rise
[Music]
again
to life
[Music]
come on ron breathe
right what is it we don't know
where is it we don't know that either
i realize it's not much to go on that's
nothing to go on
off the alley's closed down fred reckons
people need a laugh these days
i reckon he's right
[Music]
long bottom's been neglecting his
earmuffs no ma'am
he's just fainted yeah as well just
leave him there
right on we gonna
[Music]
you're on implement
guys on fire
[Music]
ah
can't leave them he's joking right
[Music]
how dare you stand where he stood
tell them how it happened that night
tell them how you looked him in the eye
a man who trusted you and killed him
tell them
[Music]
hello father
you are no son of mine
[Music]
it was in our bag when we searched i
reckon it's mine now
how did you get it um
style
[Music]
you've got to mean it harry
she killed him she deserves it
what part of this isn't living up to
your expectations did you think we were
gonna be staying in a five-star hotel
you thought you'd be back with your mum
by christmas
i just thought after all this time we
would have actually achieved something
maybe we should just stay here harry
grow old
why is it when something happens it is
always you three believe me professor
i've been asking myself the same
question for six years
you call me in mudblood he did not
mud bud's a really foul name for someone
who is muggle-born someone with
non-magic parents
someone like me
[Music]
bloody birds are menace
[Applause]
[Music]
please
ah
it shows us nothing more or less than
the deepest
and most desperate desires of our heart
you